what's up big guy how you doing
listen i'm talking about a matrix movie
i mean it's insane it really is there we
go it's good to see
nice to see you um so i listen i can't
imagine what it was like for you when
you got the call from lana to be a part
of this
what actually was like what do you for
fans of lana and for the matrix what do
you think they might be surprised to
learn about what it's really like to
make a film like this
that a lot of the
and
a lot of the
consideration was not for the movie
uh during the making of this film the
consideration was for the actors for the
experience
uh for the for the the family as lana
would call it you know um
it was about it was about making a film
but it was about having a good
experience as uh as co-workers as as
artists inside of the pandemic
and i think a lot of those themes
eventually bleed into the film
but sometimes the filmmaking was was
secondary to the experience that we were
having if that if that all makes
makes any sense
it does and it just is so unusual for a
film it's just not
you know it's not the norm for making a
movie
yeah yeah i mean it's not especially for
a movie like this that takes
so much um uh uh uh attention to
to to filmmaking detail into story and
to storyboarding into light into action
so obviously you know the the movie was
that was was a top priority um but the
spirit that the movie was made and i
think i i'll i'll call it back to that
um was
was you know almost as if the film the
film was a secondary was a byproduct of
the experience that we were having i
mean even even if i go back to my
audition process
i probably spent an hour and a half
talking about my past and you know
talking about relationships and
friendships and family uh and maybe
about 25 minutes on my feet acting uh
you know and and we sort of came to
mutual decisions decisions uh
with that type of process
because i don't want to do spoilers i'm
gonna ask you this question
um
what day of the shoot were you sitting
there
and sort of just like floored that you
were in this moment of being able to
work with keanu and be a part of this
movie because this franchise means so
much to so many people
it's probably um
about
three months into filming
um
i've had other moments but there was
maybe three months in the filming where
we're doing a scene where we're sort of
giving a nod back to
uh the original matrix and uh
and i'm wearing some of the morpheus
gear and sitting in the chair and and
keanu was there before me but he's also
projected as a younger version of
himself from maybe 20 years in the past
and that was a moment where that was a
complete
uh
mind-bending experience where i said
okay i'm in the matrix i'm in the matrix
in the matrix
in the matrix you know uh and keanu was
right in front of me um and that was you
know there was a lot of strange strange
days like that on set
my last question for you um obviously i
am overjoyed that james and you guys
have been making aquaman too i know it's
wrapped
what can you tease about block black
manta in the sequel what what can you
tell people about the sequel yeah i mean
uh it's it's another exciting adventure
i think in this one we get to see what
it looks like to have black manta you
know more in uh in the driver's seat you
know we get to see you know what it
looks like for him to be a little bit
more in charge
uh definitely you know we get to see
some more of his own personalities some
of the things that he struggled with and
some of his aspirations um and you know
and what it means for him to have a
little bit more um
more muscle a little bit more power you
know in this film so i'm excited about
introducing a more a more fleshed out
rounded you know personality to the
world
what was your reaction to the script
when you read it
i said okay let's go
okay
i honestly can't wait um i think i'm out
of time so i'm just going to stop and
say man i wish you i'm so happy for your
success and i wish you nothing but the
best it's always a pleasure to see